mein thema ist er die gasanlage wer hat
sich da durchgesetzt ja da hat christian
linder was geschickt das gemacht die
gasanlage ist ja so dass wir brauchen
plötzlich viel mehr geld weil das gas
mehr kostet weil wir nicht mehr das
russische gas habe ich erkläre ein
bisschen verkürzt und die ur idee der
grünen war lasst uns das solidarisch
machen also das ist sogar ein
bundeshaushalt machen über die
steuerzahler dann hätte man aber mehr
geld für den bundeshaushalt gebraucht
also entweder mehr schulden das steuer
und da war die fdp vor und deshalb muss
robert habeck musste sich diese gas
umlage ausdenken wie hat auch eine
solidaritäts wirkung weil jetzt alle
leute die gas kriegen zahlen egal bei
welchem verbraucher sie sind aber es
sind halt nur die leute die gas haben
und man fragt sich natürlich wie so
haben jetzt die mit der gasheizung habe
nicht mehr den russischen krieg
verursacht als die anderen also die fdp
hat habe ich da in eine gewisse härte
getrieben das heißt es ist die fdp der
wir diese gas umlage verdanken fraktion
momenten
mit werten bis zu gespritzt oder ich
würde sagen deutlich zu dieses ist ein
spitzenwert die sendung natürlich hätte
sich diese einschaltquote ist eine
bundesregierung ja sich genau mit diesem
thema auseinandersetzt wurde die
tatsache dass die energie teurer wird
aufgrund des krieges aufgrund der folgen
das beschäftigt natürlich diese
bundesregierung und deswegen muss
überlegt werden ja wie was kann kommen
wie entlastet man dann die die besonders
getroffen werden und insofern wird auch
da in der regierung entsprechen
diskutiert aber man hätte es auch mit
steuermitteln bezahlen können mal heißt
japan erhöhen man hätte ja sie hätten ja
auch eine über gewinnen steuer zum
beispiel die berühmte über gewinn steuer
mal durchsetzen können es ist nicht
eigentlich in ordnung wenn man sagt die
die definitiv von dieser krise wirklich
profitieren
milliardengewinne einstreichen die sie
sonst mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht gemacht hätten in großer
wahrscheinlichkeit ja aber die die
mittlerweile an dem punkt auch mal zur
kasse so konsequent diese eindeutigkeit
die andere länder hier auch aufbringen
spanien italien griechenland 90 england
macht es sogar in meinem das mutterland
des kapitalismus die machen dass eine
über gewinnsteuern und und wir hätten
verbraucher zur kasse die
jetzt 480 euro gruppe zahlen müssen plus
mehrwertsteuer was ironisch ist also und
auf den extras auf eine am erbe ja die
der staat erhebt jetzt noch mal ironisch
lassen aber der stab an dem mehrere
sondern nichts dafür dass wissen sie
dass christian lindner als
finanzminister bei der eu angeklopft hat
ja eher haben sie mehrwertsteuer sein
lassen
er hat es gemacht es war korrekt als
ausgemachter nein das war eigentlich
russland bitte aber das war
ja durch die serie hat in brüssel
gefragt gilt das europäische recht auch
für uns und überraschender weise hat er
die anhörung begann hat eas gilt auch
für euch tun und ja sein kann er sagen
brüssel ist schule also das land hat das
gemacht ist die frage na ja das ist doch
nicht so dass die kommission entscheidet
wer welche steuern sein dass es
europäisches recht
können hat einfach sagen für euch machen
wir das jetzt nicht weil wir euch den
gefallen tun aber sagen sie jetzt in dem
sie das jetzt in dieser klarheit sagen
sie haben gerade als erster einsatz hier
hatten in dieser sendung gesagt sie
sprechen verkürzt und erklären etwas und
das thema das auf eine abgabe die
mehrwertsteuer kommt das wissen die
wenigsten
und deswegen dieses thema zu intonieren
und zu sagen gibt es möglicherweise eine
frage dieser existenziellen frage wo wir
dem ausweichen könnt die ist eindeutig
beantwortet worden frau station ich
finde diese frage legitim weil die
meisten und ich will hier keinem zu nahe
treten diese dezidiert nicht wissen und
auf der anderen seite ist klar ist dass
robert habeck auch gesagt hat als
wirtschaftsminister dass wir das was an
mehrwertsteuer jetzt noch obendrauf
kommen dass wir uns damit gedanken
machen müssen das zu kompensieren damit
es nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger auch
noch tragen müssen denn die idee ist ja
dass durch die steuer die der staat hier
einem sozusagen der staat davon
profitiert dass diese preise jetzt
steigen genau wenn doch mal die frage
wann hat christian lindner nachgefragt
ob all diese steuer zahlen muss bei der
eben
ja vor kurzem
das heißt vor kurzem ja er hat noch luft
hat die antwort relative und nachdem die
gasanlage schon öffentlich war oder
danach oder darf ich nehme an danach
oder ich hab keine ahnung das ist doch
ein total warum wohl ein echter
fortschritt meint frey warum macht man
das nicht davor
seit wann reden wir über die gasanlage
in der deutschen politik das ist
deutlich länger als die letzten vier bis
sechs wochen ist schon lange klar dass
wir eine umlage brauchen wir müssen
irgendeine form haben um ja um die
stadtwerke zu retten um bisschen zu
retten und so weiter das ist also völlig
klar dass so was kommen wird und es wäre
doch der aufgabe gewesen aus dem
finanzministerium kurz nachzuhaken wenn
wir so was machen was bedeutet das für
die mehrwertsteuer ist doch ganz gleich
die frage hätte man sofort beantworten
können und man hätte wahrscheinlich auch
genauso schnell eine antwort bekommen
vor sechs wochen wie jetzt also insofern
muss man schon vermuten dass dahinter in
anführungsstrichen politisches kalkül
steckt das jetzt diese umlage in welcher
form sie ja auch immer also wie hoch sie
ja dann auch immer sein wird mit einer
mehrwertsteuer bedingt wird also für
mich als otto normalverbraucher in dem
fall sei das sehr nach einer schönen
strategischen geschichte aus und ich
weiß nicht was für ein ziel da wird
verfolgt werden könnte aber dass man die
öffentlichkeit nicht vorher darüber
informiert hat dass natürlich eine
mehrwertsteuer auf so eine umlage kommt
habe ich nicht verstanden
hab ich nix also angesagt ist es nicht
besonders
das würde sie in europa ein geübtes
verfahren wenn dazu eine alle regierung
etwas verkünden müssen was irgendwie nie
so gut kommt sagt man die in brüssel
sind gewesen und damit ganze wahlkämpfe
bestritten so und in diesem punkt ich
will es nicht überdramatisieren da wir
haben das ja noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen er würde gerne auf die
steuer verzichten und einen tag später
hat dann die kommission gesagt das geht
leider nicht es steht im gesetz also das
war ja aber er hat sich das aus einem
grund gesagt noch mal dass in einer
krise diese umlage kommt sie haben
gerade erklärt und das daraufhin noch
steuern fallen mehrwertsteuer lief ließ
dem die steht fließt dem deutschen staat
zugute und was christian lindner damit
sagen wollte ist da kommt eine umlage
das heißt die energie wird noch euro für
die menschen in diesem land und jetzt
verdient deutschland auch noch daran
dass die abgabe steigt und das nicht
aber immer
denkt man man kann eine diskussion
führen über rhetorik oder wann man was
sagt aber er sei in diesem kontext sich
menschen zu sagen da kommt die
mehrwertsteuer drauf glauben sie mir wir
denken immer jeder weiß hier alles aber
sie sind wissenschaftler und sie ein
bisschen manchen dingen viel viel mehr
als wir und als der rest der republik
nur als unser glück also ich habe ja
erst mal wenn sie können sich jetzt
nicht frei machen das sie über
die kreisumlage ist man über die
gasanlage
läuft ja schon eine ganze weile aber
ganz egal wann man sie angefangen das
wird von vornherein klar dass darauf 19
prozent steuer kommt das sagen sie er
hat verstanden alle anderen habe es auch
verstanden und sie meinen 83 millionen
haben es nicht verstanden die haben
sondern verstanden
warum man sie also warum bist du
kommuniziert soll man wollte montag
erstmal den nettobetrag sagen und nicht
den bruttobetrag weil der nettobetrag
war schon hoch genug und das sollte man
noch sagen muss die bösen aus brüssel
lassen uns euch nicht die steuern
erlassen das ist auch okay aber das ist
politische pr
wenn sie einen artikel schreiben machen
sie auch erklären sie dinge und das ist
für sie als journalist auch ein stück pr
ich verstehe die aufregung gar nicht
tatsache ist doch tatsache ist doch dass
er damit den menschen klar gemacht hat
dass er den menschen klar gemacht hat
dass daraufhin noch eine steuer kommt
also ich muss mich jetzt nicht ständig
wiederholen die dem startet so gut gab
das heißt der deutsche staat verdient
daran dass etwas kommt was man gerne
verhindert hätte aktion war jetzt ist
auch leuten die sich damit nicht
beschäftigen und glauben sie mir wir
glauben immer dass alle menschen sich
mit allen beschäftigen ist klar dass es
nicht funktioniert dass brüssel das
einfordert aber das gute ende ist das
auch haarweg in dem moment sagen musste
okay diese differenz von netto vom
brutto werden wir kompensieren müssen
und ich finde unter dem strich ist damit
klar frau dass sich der staat dass er
das was er an mehr gewinn hat durch
diese mehrwertsteuer in den bürgerinnen
und bürgern zurück gibt das fast immer
auch in cannes vorwerfen dass sie
intellektuell licher vordermann sind sie
wissen ja ganz genau warum sie geht es
ist doch es sieht aus wie ein
taschenspielertrick ich war also man
geht nach vorne und sagt da haben wir
jetzt diese 480 euro die im schnitt auf
eine vierköpfige familie zukommt dann
haben wir ja und jetzt dummerweise die
in brüssel jetzt wollen ja auch noch die
märchen steuer obendrauf das ist doch
grotesk
kommunikation ist doch zu sagen wir
haben hier 480 euro gasanlage und die
schlechte nachricht ist leider kommen
auch noch 19 prozent mehrwertsteuer oben
braucht ihr nicht ablesen dass genau
diese differenz wo brüssel sagt nee
europäisches recht muss bezahlt werden
das jetzt jedem klar ist dass diese
differenz der staat daran nicht verdient
sondern eher den bürgerinnen das
zurückgibt was sie wollen ich finde das
völlig in ordnung das war doch schon
vorher klar und entlastungs paket ist
auch schon angekündigt dass nicht nur
die mehrwertsteuer entlastet wird so
ganz scheint erstmal finden dabei
rauskommen schauen sie der hat den trick
gemacht es ist auch nicht so schlimm wir
haben ihn erst
[Gelächter]
jetzt diesen selbst befriedigen das
jetzt wirklich selbstbefriedigung dass
sie glauben sie hätten ihn bei irgendwas
erwischt wie ich einzelne er seine
millionen von menschen sorge haben vor
der preiserhöhung sie haben gerade
gesagt über 400 bis 500 euro das ist ja
richtig geld das ist im schnitt 40 50
euro im jahr und eine frage und deswegen
ist es doch hier keine keinen job der
selbstverpflegung da haben wir jetzt
jemand erwischt dann ist die aufgabe den
menschen zu erklären was gerade passiert
jetzt werde ich noch mal deutlich wenn
lernende regierung bediente montags den
leuten sagt ihr müsst diese
mehrwertsteuer vielleicht nicht bezahlen
und dienstag sagt opec ihr müsst die
doch bezahlen weil brüssel ist schuld
dann ist das keine ehrliche
kommunikation dass die regierung von
vornherein wusste dass wie jede
gasrechnung und jede rechnung in
deutschland mit mehrwertsteuer kommt und
das war kein heldenhafter kampf um die
bürger zu entlasten sondern das war ein
blame game das war ein das war kein plan
gehen das war das auch auf die schwarze
peter spiel das war in die
bundesregierung hinein kommuniziert
diese differenz die jetzt auf uns
zukommen also dieses plus der
mehrwertsteuer werden wir als staat
regierung michael sie ihren mist okay
wir wissen nicht ob das sonst gekommen
war stand ich habe damit ein ganz
anderes problem und zwar wirklich noch
mal die frage sie sagten gerade zurecht
wiesen sie darauf hin sie kommen aus der
kommunalpolitik wenngleich auch ist im
vergleich wohlhabenden düsseldorf aber
das ist viel geld für leute werden uns
gestern mal angeschaut
die die gaspreisentwicklung ganz
grundsätzlich august 20 21 zahlt eine
vierköpfige familie im schnitt 1280 euro
ein jahr später sind wir bei
3600 euro verdreifacht vervierfacht je
nach anbieter jetzt kommt das noch
obendrauf das heißt am ende landest du
bei
4203 1000 euro mehr ist noch mal die
frage warum mutet man das läuten zu
warum ist es für ihre partei an dem
punkt nicht möglich zu sagen dass oft
anlass uns bitte die gewinne erst mal
abschöpfen die leute besteuern die
großkonzerne besteuern die richtig kasse
gemacht haben in dieser krise so wie es
die italiener auch gemacht haben jetzt
sogar verlängert haben und zwar ohne
zusätzliche leistung bringen das ist die
zeit der geschichte hier geben sich
wieder lohnen weg sagt sondern hier wird
einfach mit dem kleinen konzert viel
viel viel mehr geld verdient ja da ist
der po bei letztlich also erstmal wissen
sie ja nie in welcher situation welches
unternehmen mehr geld verdient das
können sie ja vorher nicht wissen
wenn sie einmal mit diesem wieso wissen
die anderen parteien grundsätzlich
entschuldigung ich mache mir jetzt
gedanken sie haben mir eine frage ja ja
ja so und die die frage ist dieses wort
über gewinn steuer also ein gewinn ist
ein gewinn es gibt kein übergewicht und
werden oder es gibt kein den gewinn zwar
das interesse begriff ist egal wie der
begriff ist nicht egal weil jeder auf
gewinne steuern zahlt und das in der
progression der steuerprogression die
die eine besonders hohe steuer zahlen zu
recht das ist ja die idee das geht ja
nicht so sondern es geht so um auch
entsprechend mehr steuern zahlen und
wenn sie anfangen dieses argument
vorzutragen dann wird es vielleicht in
einem jahr ein anderes thema geben
nehmen sie kroner um das mal wird das
ist ja nach wie vor der haben sie ein
pharmazeutisches unternehmen könnte ich
das beispiel ist überhaupt kein
schlechtes beispiel da gibt es ein
pharmazeutisches unternehmen die
entwickeln einen am impfstoff verdienen
damit unvorstellbar viel geld
übrigens zahlen die jetzt an die kommune
wo es entwickelt wurde besonders viel
geld ich war nämlich progressiv viel hat
die stadt mainz an gewerbesteuer
bekommen ihre argumentation wäre dass
dieses pharmazeutische unternehmen was
sozusagen jetzt unglaublich viel geld
verdient hat weil plötzlich dieser virus
uns alle erfasst das ist diesmal der
argumentation der stadt wäre eindeutig
nein nein überhaupt gar nicht so fern
dass die gebrüder strüngmann heißen sie
hexal gründer und so weiter die
maßgeblich bei
wie heißt die firma war und dank
mitfinanziert haben in mainz die sehr
viel geld in die hand genommen haben um
diesen impfstoff zu entwickeln
wir sind ein risiko eingegangen
und wenn sie sich anschauen was dietmar
hopp ein anderer sehr wohlhabender mann
dieses landes was der parcours weg in
tübingen gemacht hat denn das gleiche
versucht ist exakt die gleiche technik
messenger rna der hat viele viele
millionen in die hand genommen und am
ende hat es nicht funktioniert chur weg
hat dieses rennen verloren und liegt mal
hopp hat mutmaßlich sehr viel geld
verloren da ist jemand in ein risiko
gegangen und die gebrüder stunden waren
die hexal gründer sind auch in ein
risiko gegangen bei kontakt und am ende
hat die menschheit davon profitiert das
geld hätte auch ganz einfach weg sein
können risikokapital erklären sie mir
bitte welche mineralölfirma hat welches
risiko auf sich genommen um jetzt an der
zapfsäule abzukassieren länge mal breite
also wenn sie hier wenn wir diese
diskussion grundsätzlich führen man wird
weil jeder krise situation die unter
umständen die menschheit brauche oder
jetzt mal ganz konkret leute die
menschen die in deutschland leben
beutelt wie diese diskussion führen wer
entscheidet denn dann wann wer was
verdienen kann weil sie in krisen das
ist keine gute kein guter ausgang der
geschichte weil sie in krisen übrigens
selbst bei corona selbst beim ukraine
krieg immer auch unternehmen haben die
relativ viel plötzlich an dieser krise
verdienen und dann werden wir hier jedes
mal sofern wir eingeladen werden noch
mal diskutieren darüber diskutieren wann
wird welches unternehmen welche branche
jetzt besonders zur kasse gebeten weil
sie als markus lanz sagen so gar kein
risiko eingegangen die diskussion ist
eine diskussion die werden wir gar nicht
will ich es nicht machen ich mir jetzt
nur darum neben aber nicht womöglich
weiß denn so funktioniert auch
marktwirtschaft nur ein punkt ist ein
anderer ich will einfach nur darauf
hinaus es ist eine ausnahmesituation um
menschen haben energie
preisentwicklungen in einem jahr
hinnehmen müssen so vorher nicht an so
jetzt kommt noch einmal die 480 plus
märchen steuer oben drauf und wir sitzen
da und sagen wir sollen das eigentlich
gehen was macht das eigentlich mit den
sozialen zusammenhalt eines landes aber
das ist ich glaube der harald lesch
trinkt sein bier noch kurz zu ende und
sagt dann was er darüber denkt und
natürlich gerne und voller fragen wie
sehen sie das
also ich bin ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
sprachlos weil
bei montech oder irgendwelche anderen
firmen und deren gewinne
sind so sagen wirklich unabhängig von
dem risiko sind
gezielt erzielt worden das heißt dass
eine firma gegründet worden mit dem
ausdrücklichen ziel einen bestimmten
impfstoff zu erzeugen der nun ja auch
wirklich ziemlich positive wirkung hatte
die erdölkonzern haben ihre gewinne rx 8
ich weiß nicht wie groß es wirklich ist
weil die zahlen sind ja ganz
unterschiedlich sie sind selbst für
einen ausgemachten kapitalisten
eigentlich unanständig sie sind wie
karen pittel es ja auch gesagt hat
schlechte gewinne weil es sind gewinne
aus fossilen ressourcen also das gestern
gewinnen das heißt wir hätten noch ganz
andere gründe hierzu sagen freunde für
drei oder vier oder fünf oder sechs
monate vielleicht sogar begrenzt nur für
eine gewisse zeit müssen wir an das geld
ran weil wir brauchen es woanders also
ganz egal wie die wm die
begrifflichkeiten da sind halte ich es
für unbedingt notwendig dass gerade dann
damit damit er mit der hand lux fähig
bleiben denn es wird ein
entlastungspaket nach dem anderen geben
währenddessen neben jetzt wirklich
milliardenbeträge in unternehmen hinein
laufen die genau das gegenteil von dem
tun was wir eigentlich haben wollen also
nämlich vor allen dingen in die
erneuerbaren reinzugehen überhaupt eine
infrastruktur bereitzustellen dass wir
das machen können und dass wir diese
diese brücke diese zeit dehnungen die
wir jetzt vor uns haben dass wir diese
brückentechnologien beziehungsweise
diese brücke überhaupt hinkriegen über
die über die verschiedenen varianten die
wir alle kennen ich bin also ich bin
erstaunt
darüber dass wir in deutschland anderen
ländern sie haben ja gesagt wie viel
den praktisch unterstellen dass sie
grundsätzlich
falsche entscheidungen getroffen habe
bei der über gewinn steuer denn so hörte
sich also es gibt die andere branche
übrigens auch von krisen profitieren
reden wir doch mal hin
sie wissen ja dass hier ist die krise
warum haben wir diese krise weil wir
durch die große koalition
abhängig geworden von russland energie
zu bekommen losgelöst von der thematik
die sie jetzt gesagt haben dass man
nicht früher aus fossilen brennstoffen
rausgegangen das ist ja jetzt mal
tatsache das können wir nicht ändern so
das heißt jetzt muss eine antwort
gefunden werden und die mehrheit war der
meinung wir müssen so schnell wie
möglich aus dieser abhängigkeit nicht
ganz raus gehen glaube das ist jetzt
erst mal eine tatsache so gibt es
natürlich auch andere themen auslöser
ukraine nehmen sie den ganzen bereich
der industrie die in rüstung investieren
übrigens bei lichte betrachtet
unternehmerisch auch ein risiko die
verdienen jetzt auch geld weil plötzlich
werden bestimmte waffensysteme gebaut
plötzlich wird die kapazität hoch da
würde jeder der damit nichts anfangen
kann die machen sich jetzt die taschen
voll ist immens die gleiche
argumentation
naja eben nicht
mit der linie ist genau das risiko dass
genau
lassen sie mich nur den gedanken zu
einem film das heißt sie haben natürlich
in solchen krisen immer auch unternehmen
die in dem moment geld verdienen dass
das hat es sich aber doch nicht so viel
wie die öbb die mineralölkonzerne aber
es geht doch da hast du mineral über das
geht gerade um gras das neue jahr sind
energiekonzerne hinein das ist erstmal
zwei unterschiedliche dinge für
unterschiedliche branchen energie
verkauft und auch das unterschiedliche
unternehmen warum haben die diese gas
umlage gemacht weil ein unternehmen uni
per
sonst pleite mitwirken wer die anderen
übrigens nicht und diese leute haben wie
niemand sonst auf großen glas gesetzt
die haben sogar artikel veröffentlich
als management und geworben für die
eröffnung von 19 2 und so weiter und die
anderen im markt sagen schon wir wollen
gar nicht das geld aus dieser gas umlage
wird es nicht brauchen rwe zum beispiel
also auch in diesem markt konnte man
sich richtig entscheiden und falsch oder
vielleicht falsch und weniger falsch so
und das wird diese dieses ein
unternehmen was so krass daneben gelegt
klien hat jetzt retten ist bedauerlich
marktwirtschaftlich aber muss vielleicht
seien aber darauf eine diskussion für
die moralisierung des steuerrechts zu
setzen da wäre ich wirklich vorsichtig
wollte ich erinnere mich noch als corona
war und man auch gesagt hat muster so
viel verdient werden bei marion tag
müssen man den die patente abnehmen und
so fort also wenn eine
bundestagsmehrheit entscheiden dürfte
welche branche kriegt welche steuer und
darauf läuft es hinaus ich glaube nicht
dass das clever ist der möchte ich doch
noch mal fragen wie ist das in den
anderen ländern gelaufen wie ist das da
baby hat wird großbritannien zum
beispiel sich 90 prozent über gewinn
steuer im parlament durch durchgebracht
wie war das noch mal schauen sie das was
johnson diesen populären reflex nicht
widerstehen kann das ist ehrlich gesagt
nicht gar nicht sagen dass
unsere haben märz schon gemacht haben es
dann eine freimenge hat wenn spanier
haben uns gestern gemacht ich frage mich
halt immer muss man aus alledem
angesichts jetzt einer ganz konkreten
notsituationen einer situation der
menschen echten schwierigkeiten geraten
muss man nur mal mit ostdeutschen
ministerpräsidenten zum beispiel auch
sprechen mit reiner haseloff morgen bei
uns zu gast und anderen die erzählen
dann das auch muss man da nicht mal ein
bisschen pragmatischer agieren sowie ist
die italiener die griechen und andere
gemacht habe warum müssen wir immer so
furchtbar grundsätzlich werden und jetzt
ist gleich dem marktwirtschaft in gefahr
weil wir sollten also wenn man im
bundestag eine abstimmung macht welche
branche oder welches unternehmen
gerichtet welchen steuersatz dann
kriegen wir echt verwegene debatten ja
ich also dann würde ich wirklich von
abraten das ist auch also das ist
ordnungspolitisch falsch und das ist
politisch schwer es auch falsch juni
platzierten entschuldigung
ordnungspolitisch ist es auch falsch
leute zur kasse zu bitten zur
entschuldung der handel überhaupt keine
verträge hatten
mit pellets haben
dafür in deutschland wollen wir
überhaupt noch genforschung und dann
spielen wir zehn jahre vor und da sehen
wir mehr technologie ist aber jetzt
super
hätte der bundestag sagen soll ich sagen
dass ich sage jetzt fürchten nicht
unpopulär aber und die erhalt sehr
grundsätzlich ja das ist auch richtig so
und
schaust du da drauf ja ich bin jetzt
fast zwölf jahre nicht in europa gewesen
und deutschland gewesen und bin seit
freitag wieder hier was ich ganz
spannend findet dass sofern kenne ich
wie details nicht aus ich glaube ich
spannend finde was die historische
zeitenwende ist die man begrifflich
geklärt hat das ist eine unglaubliche
verteilungsdiskussion und auch ein
kämpfer reinkommen werden und man auch
bereit sein muss wahrscheinlich völlig
neu zu denken auch was ist
marktwirtschaft das ist kapitalismus
ich fand es nicht nochmal die debatte
mit mit ihrem parteivorsitzenden lindner
auf machen ich habe die argument auch
verstanden aber ich glaube schon in dem
er noch mal klar machen wollte wer für
diese mehrwertsteuer schuld ist geht es
auch wieder um verteilung das machen wir
nicht und darauf ist eigentlich diese
gesellschaft nicht dass mit china
vergleiche nur bedingt vorbereitet weil
wir eben doch auch von einem wohlstands
lesungen ich weiß dass das eine
schwieriger sei es weil viele menschen
uns auch zur kopie das jetzt auch schon
nicht so gut geht aber trotzdem unsere
leitungs leidensfähigkeit wesentlich
geringer ausgeprägt ist als zum beispiel
in china wenn ich ein beispiel dafür
bringen darf es wird jetzt immer glaube
ich die zahl dass es dann nur 19 grad im
winter vielleicht ist ja wenn es nicht
funktioniert wenn man sich natürlich
china anguckt das treffen des landes
entweder überhaupt keine heizung hat ja
das sind also hunderte von millionen und
wenn wir dann auch die debatte führen
dass wir uns auch vielleicht mit china
anlegen wollen weil wir der ansicht sind
was in taiwan machen oder was sie bei
den uiguren machen also wenn wir von 19
grad angst haben dann wird das mit china
ganz schwierig oder dadurch dass
richtigkeit und all dies finde ich sind
diese verteilungs niemanden und ich war
ja mal von 1994 bis 2008 auch im
hauptstadtstudio und natürlich finde ich
wenn ich das sagen darf jetzt nicht sie
persönlich hat die politik natürlich
versäumt auch immer wieder die großen
reformen der sozialsysteme der
demografische faktor ich war in den 14
jahren habe ich etwa
600 rentenreform erlebt mit horst
seehofer wer alles aber im grunde um die
grundsätzliche frage wie war das neu
verteilen hat man hat man nicht gelöst